i can just tell you right now there are
no talks of
insync ever doing anything ever again we
have to move on and just you know
remember the good times i have a lot to
talk to you about so let's
start with the daily podcast you have
been doing this
every single day i think that you're
over 200 episodes now 250 episodes
yeah we're about 250 now yeah wow okay
what is it like to do that in quarantine
i mean is there much of a
difference it has been a lifesaver you
know with podcasts it's just been
amazing and thank goodness i started
this show right before lockdown because
if i didn't have this
every day i would have been going crazy
at home
because like i said all of my all my
projects are on hold right now so
this has really just kept me going it's
been nice to be able to
talk to the fans out there and and it's
just been it's been a godsend for sure
you mentioned too a lot of your other
projects were on hold like what's what's
on hold right now
um well i have a film that i'm doing
with tristar uh which i'm super excited
about we've been working on this for
quite a while and we're about to
announce the writer
of this which everyone's going to love
uh but it's a
it's a true story about these two girls
that won a winnebago on the price is
right and decided they wanted to follow
us on tour
for three months and uh it was the
craziest story they hatched the plan
it worked it's a true story i mean it's
insane yeah just go look at the
winnebago girls on on google and
you'll see this i mean it's the weirdest
thing so we're uh
we're recreating that story but of
course it happens 20 years later so you
know
they're older trying to recapture this
this amazing trip they did
20 years ago can you star in it
uh i will not star in no no it is a it
is a female-led
comedy for sure it's a very amazing road
trip movie but they're following a boy
band
right yes yeah yeah they will be
following in sync
who do you cast as instinct well i have
my list
uh you know in the movie i'm sure it'll
be a fictitious band but
everyone will know it's us um so the
stunt casting
uh i want to have a really fun with and
you'll definitely uh
you'll love the guys that we pick it'll
be all your favorite little a-listers
can you throw out one name for us all
right one that i really really want is
ryan reynolds i think he would really
just
you know really make this ban and i
think just having that amazing
funny cameo at the end with all those
amazing
guys would be hilarious have you talked
to ryan about this
um i have not talked in person about it
but i think his people know about it and
they're you know they're like okay
let us read the script when it's done
[Music]
aj mclean on dancing with the stars i
know you guys are friends i have a
picture actually of you me and him at
lisa's 40th
did you give him any advice before he
went on the show
i did yeah i mean i i love aj he's the
best and i'm so glad that uh
he got partnered with cheryl who i just
absolutely love i mean they really could
win this whole thing like it is a good
partnership so i'm excited to see his
growth
uh in this show um i told him you know
obviously i gave him the advice of what
he's about to go through
no one realizes how hard this is
and how taxing it is on your body so uh
you know
every day i ask him like have you broken
a toe yet and he hasn't yet
um but you know he's having a great time
and
yeah i mean it's a stressful three
months for sure but when you come out of
it
you're gonna feel like you can do
anything you've done dancing
joey's done dancing on the backstreet
boys side we've had nick and now aj
who do you think from backstreet boys in
think
could do dancing with the stars next i
mean is it jc
well i don't think jc would ever do it
uh you know jc likes to
um just you know be by himself like he
he doesn't like the attention really so
i don't think he would ever
do a show like that but if he did he'd
win it hands down
jc is one of the best dancers i've i've
ever known i mean it would be amazing
but no
he'll he'll never do it well speaking of
backstreet boys instinct you did
make the internet go wild when you
posted that picture of you and nick
carter
that was nick's eye that was not my
doing i did not want to do that
you guys knew people were gonna freak
out
is there ever a world in which
backstreet boys and instinct
ever collaborate go on tour together
has this ever been a discussion um it
has not been a real discussion at all of
course it's been a nice theory
you know in a lot of people's heads um
in a perfect world of course that would
be so much fun we would love that uh
um but i don't think in our world
that that will ever happen why do you
say that
give the fans what they want i know i
wish i could i really do i don't want to
get the fans hopes up
at all right um and i can just tell you
right now there are no
talks of instinct ever doing anything
ever again so
i just i would just go with that and be
like well
we're never gonna get another instinct
song or anything like that so
yeah just we we have to move on and just
you know
remember the good times how do you feel
about that is that
that sad for you or are you like happy
to sort of believe that it's been a long
time since i've been
you know with insane people still look
at me as that teenager uh but you know
i've
i've definitely grown a lot since then
that was kind of like our college years
um but of course it would be so much fun
at
you know my age uh to be able to get
back on the road and to have so much fun
because
you know bands like that uh you get into
that nostalgia area you know where
you can tour for years because you know
just everyone wants to
revert back to a great time that they
remember when they were younger
what was the last thing that you guys
talked about in the instinct
group chat obviously it's not touring or
doing anything no new music
no it's all it's all about babies you
know it's all about the new one that
they just brought in so uh
yeah it's all been conversations about a
newborn
is is the baby so cute do you know the
name
uh i can i'm not gonna tell that name
good question but there's no way he
would he would kill me
all right but the baby's cute of course
i'm gonna look it's just in a justice
baby of course it is
the 20-year anniversary of celebrity is
next year
will you guys do anything it is
isn't that crazy will you do anything
to to celebrate that milestone album
even if it's just like new merch i mean
i
know look we would you know we do ruin a
merch company now which is a lot of fun
so we'll definitely have some nice 20th
anniversary stuff for that
uh but nothing really planned right now
we we were trying to plan something for
the no strings attached 20th last year
um and because of coronavirus it really
just kind of got
ruined um but so i don't know if we're
going to try to do it again for
celebrity um
you know it's it's just hard right now
it's it's hard to do
anything you know with this pandemic
hearing all the
the baby news and the baby talk i mean
you guys are
in your instinct group chat talking
about it i can't help
but kind of feel for you and michael and
the journey that you guys
have gone on and you've been very vocal
about what's happened
i know you lost the surrogate earlier
this year so
so how are you guys doing uh with
everything
involving that yeah you know we're still
staying positive uh you know we know
that this process can be long
we have several friends that have gone
through ivf and
um you know it's it's it's not as
perfect as everybody you know it's like
you think oh it'll happen the first time
it hardly ever you know works the first
time so we knew that going in and we're
just trying to stay positive we're now
going on
three years with this but it looks like
things are
gonna be great um you know we we have a
surrogate now we have our donor so
hopefully uh soon we'll be able to uh
celebrate yeah you did find a new
surrogate
we yes i think so yeah we well we found
a surrogate but of course that can
always fall out any day
so uh but yes right now we do have a
surge
okay and i is adoption something that
you would ever consider or do you want
to do the surrogacy
route is that like 100 no we we always
uh you know wanted to adopt um you know
our game plan
was to you know do the ivf and have our
kids
and then be able to adopt you know the
next ones um
now we might have to switch that you
know so if this doesn't work this next
time
we'll just go ahead and go ahead and
adopt we're totally fine with that we're
we'd want to do that i think it's so
important to uh you know
take kids out of you know these
orphanages and
uh you know it's a sad situation that so
many kids have to
live in these homes um so we would love
to welcome someone
into our home at some point i i love how
positive
you're being because i think a lot of
people i mean you've done nine rounds of
ivf and i think a lot of people would be
disheartened by that so how do you guys
maintain the positivity just to clarify
we never did we never were pregnant nine
times we just never
got to that we've only been pregnant
twice uh so we
we didn't uh or with two um so yeah so
it so we never got to the point where we
were pregnant and then lost so we would
always get to the point before we would
implant and then things would go awry
so uh so yeah it's it's a little less
dramatic than a lot of people
think of like oh my gosh you went
through nine pregnancies no it was
it was not that okay all right that's
good to know though i'm glad that you're
like
that's great because i read that and i
was like i know yeah that would that
would be
a lot yeah looking ahead i mean what
does the lance bass
empire kind of look like in the next
five to ten
years i mean you said you're going to be
producing podcasts for other people
you're putting together movies i mean
kind of walk me through what the vision
is
it's kind of like what my whole life has
been just a little bit of everything
you know the next 10 years i'm
definitely focusing on having the family
but
uh but work wise um really bumping up
the producing of television and film
um you know i have a i have a show that
i'm actually going to be starring in
also
so i'll be able to you know act and get
in front of the camera again but
you know there's a there's a finite time
that this face can be in front of the
camera so
i'm going to start i want to start
setting myself up you know for my
my golden years and uh and i really want
to build out lance bash productions and
make it
you know an amazing production company